[Music]
CBS News has suspended our co-host
Charlie Rose at the top of Tuesday
morning's broadcast Gayle King and Norah
O'Donnell respond to sexual misconduct
allegations against their former co-host
after eight women claimed Rose made
unwanted sexual advances to them while
they worked on his PBS show in the 90s
through 2011 this will be investigated
this has to end
this behavior is wrong period
I certainly echo that and I I have to
say Nora I really am still reeling I got
an hour and 42 minutes to sleep last
night both my son and my daughter called
me Oprah called me and said are you okay
I am NOT okay Kings best friend Oprah
recently opened up to et about the issue
of sexual harassment in Hollywood I'm
not happy that it happened the way that
it did but this moment is I feel a
seminal moment it's a really moment it's
a real really powerful time for
everybody to get woke 75 year-old
Charlie has since issued a statement
apologizing for his alleged past
behavior writing in part I have behaved
in sensitively at times and I accept
responsibility for that et has learned
Charlie has now been let go from CBS
this morning Gale has shared the morning
news desk with Charlie for the past five
years but says she is clearly on the
side of the women who have come forward
Charlie does not get a pass here he
doesn't get a pass from anyone in this
room we were all deeply affected we were
all rocked by this he doesn't get a pass
because I can't stop thinking about the
anguish of these women what happened to
their dignity what happened to their
bodies what happened maybe to even their
careers I'm still trying to process all
of this I'm still trying to sort it out
Gail says she has yet to speak to
Charlie but plans on reaching out
[Music]
you